I
would a woman has a higher chance of
Landing a job at 40 re-entering the
workplace and getting an education
thanks affirmative action maybe she goes
with your doctor that's nominated by men
versus being 40 years old and trying to
bring a child to full term sure you
would just be completely wrong do you
think it's like a 70 chance of like a
miscarriage woman is pregnant at 40.
it's significantly higher Bros like 90
okay at that point men like this men
like this simp and Pander to women
he's telling me
it's gonna be harder to get a job
it's harder to get a job at 40 than it
is to have a kid so I just Googled this
fertility specialist quote approximately
a five percent chance of getting
pregnant per menstrual cycle I mean I
wasn't even in social media until three
years ago two years ago
look what I built in two three years